citizens of the reject Nation
it is me Tara Erickson alongside
oh spooky spooky spooky season yet we
are watching Scott Pilgrim Vs the World
I have never seen this movie what
about you Gregory all right here's
yours came out on Blu-ray I rented it a lot
of my first time rewatches as either I just
don't remember or Greg was the you know a lot
back then so when I started this movie I got
maybe 15 minutes in and realized I'm not in
the proper headspace to process this film and
you turned it off I turned it off and I N that
in the movie never went back and it never went
back to that in the movie Warrior or the two
movies I've done that with oh very different
films I've never just finished them and now I'm
like well let's do it let's finally watch this
movie we're gonna stick to it no matter
what okay and you guys better not forget
tearing the Bell to subscribe to subscribe
and lastly don't forget if you're not already
a patron you should become one because you
get the full reaction oh watch along where
you get to sync up with your own copy and
watch the entire Scott Pilgrim versus the
world with me and Gregory which is
insane it's like you're sitting in
your house you're watching it but we're
also there with you let's get into it
oh that's neat took a Mario Brothers thing I
believe this is based on a comic book oh Scott
Pilgrim is dating a high schooler really is she
hot it's the first question you've been out of
high school for like 13 years I'm 22. that's gross
have you even kissed her we almost held Hance once
but then she got embarrassed so what's her name
knives ciao what so when do we get to meet her
oh please let it be soon that's for me oh it's
cool little text hi you promise to be good of
course I'll be good hey nice this is Steven
Stills the talent the talent wow hey let me
get you covered can you play the drums yes awesome
nice that's Young Neil hi hi it just lives there
that's right man some sexy ass rock and rollers
okay and I love him
oh Anna Kendrick I didn't realize
how many times yeah this might be the
only Edgar Wright movie I didn't finish
what I've seen every other one oh yeah
this might be the only one before you
hear some dirty lies from someone
else yes I'm dating a 17 year old
wow
17 years old Scandal that's not true who told
you Wallace duh that gossipy [__] already
Wallace he's so quick it's been over a year since
you got dumped by she who will not be named so
oh there she is good old Captain Marvel
I do not want to be here at all
this girl has boys too this is
like spider-verse before spider verse
my cool gay roommate Wallace Wells hi
he's gay oh do you wanna know who my class
is gay yes does he wear glasses flawless
here we go
God I love the symmetry of
these shots yeah like wow
It's a combination of a fighting game
it's like Mortal Kombat plus dancing wow
oh God he wants her to pay come on Scott so he
just wants the company but doesn't want the actual
intimacy maybe he doesn't know how well I knew I
personally rocked but I never suspected that we
rocked as a unit so thank you Knox I mean you guys
are gonna be huge that's a hell of a transition
party Friday or will you be busy has issues
babysitting oh so I guess the texts are from
his perspective and the atoms is so cool do you
read her blog I'm sorry you were saying about me I
mean I've never gone out with anyone so talented I
like these transitions I know they're amazing cool
foreign well they're holding hands so there's
some intimacy for you Greg I mean it's kind of
creepy though isn't it a little bit worse
I would have felt better she was eight 18.
whoa trippy huh so alone you're not alone
you're just having some idiotic dream
does that mean we can make out speaking of
new weren't you supposed to take your fake
high school girlfriend to the library a half
hour ago what it's like six in the morning
libraries remind me of grade school
that's Mary I love her so much the
dream girl do you know that girl
Scott what is your girlfriend distracting
you I'll be quiet ER oh oh my God this poor
girl he treats her like such a big [__] yeah
I'm gonna go pee due to boredom I love the way
you shot him he's just like what there's
like a quirky comic book symmetry to it
everyone right yeah pretty much you know this
one girl was here like this yes that's Ramona
Flowers oh my God what I gotta tell you though
I hear that she's a little hardcore oh wait
are we now on the hunt for Romano flowers while
he's in a serious relationship with knives ciao
nothing hey you know Pac-Man look at his cup
well Pac-Man was originally called Puck man
they changed it because people would change
scratch out the P turn it into an F like
oh God he's doctor until she laughed that's
amazing I hope she has boyfriend yes I know
back in your yard she's on another level
she's meant dying at her feet she's caught
some Battle Scars dude she sounds like a
complicated woman complicatedly cool Scott
I forbid you from hitting on Ramona even if you
haven't had a real girlfriend in over a year
great use of lighting besides I'm not even sure
she did have a big breakup she keeps mentioning
some guy named Gideon yeah I don't know what it
is about that girl forget it Scott wow the whip
snap dialogue in this movie love it I've never
been so sure about something then you should
break up with your fake high school girlfriend
yeah you're thinking of juggling two chicks not
even wait who told you Wallace stuff he's not
even conscious there is like a choreography and
a dance to this movie yeah like you gotta plan
out these shots hardcore yeah it has come to my
attention that we will be fighting soon my name
is Matthew Patel and I'm fighting soon over what
I feel so bad for this girl yeah
he's doing it he won't he won't do it he doesn't
have the balls the guts I got us a show oh my gosh
when dude he's not exactly the most likable
guy yeah he's not Michael ceremony yeah
this like apathetic aloof kind of individual
she makes me want to dye my hair hot pink
and get water blades wow the
production design is through
the roof on this you need to sign for
this all right I dreamed that you were
delivering me this package is that
weird it's not weird at all it's not
do you want to hang out sometime get to know each
other I say yes so it's time for your damn package
yeah so yeah eight o'clock so see right I
love it what do you do oh I'm in between
jobs at the moment it's a beautiful shot yeah
I think Act of God is a pretty decent excuse
for a lousy date so this is a day day I think
there's a thingy over here somewhere a door
oh wow wow getting like a Sunshine Vibes
yeah especially the over the head shot
with the footprints like such a dream like
choices of filmmaking what kind of tea do
you want there's more than one kind not into
her place blueberry raspberry ginseng sleepy
time green tea green tea with lemon green tea
with lemon and honey liver disaster she's a
tea gal let me get you a blanket that would
actually be awesome foreign kind of aura that
her yeah yeah dude I'm changing ah sorry crazy
yeah that's very warm what is that oh okay
good for you Scott but aren't you still in a
relationship with knives Chow yeah man what
about her teeth I can not have to oh dang okay
it's going down I changed my mind I don't wanna
have sex with you girl all right now Pilgrim what
this is nice just this thank you that's sweet damn
how do they do those match Cuts come to the first
round of this battle of the bands thing you have
a band yeah we're terrible please come sure can
I get your number oh wow girl number girl number
this movie knows how to play with your
senses I'm Stacy okay this is Wallace's
roommate hey this is my boyfriend
Jimmy hey oh and this he's got glasses
knives dude bro
oh man my name is Crash and he's
the boys they have a girl drummer
This song is called I am so sad
goes a little something like this
thank you
thank you wow this is like so cool you see
why I had a hard time keeping up with this
this is a nightmare we need to play
now and Loud okay oh my goodness
the words
these little things they
planted are so funny to do too
consider our fight pick up
what the [__] is going on
wow what the [__] is happening right now
how do they do it
holy junk
foreign game like foreshadowing
this happening I guess I mean it
definitely seems that there must
just be love decipher later I'm
Ramona's first evil ex-boyfriend oh it's
Ramona that's bringing all this in first
evil what does that mean her first evil
boyfriend so she's had multiple whoa cool
didn't you get my email explaining the
situation oh he's the Amazon email yeah
sweet cool
yes
it was football season and for some reason all
the little jocks wanted me Matthew was the only
non-white non-jock boy in town the two of us
joined forces and we took them all down is this
how their comic looks you'll pay for this flowers
if you oh my God it's also a musical yes what
ah my goodness what my demon hipster chicks
whoa how can this be open
your eyes maybe you'll see
that's pretty awesome
cool tell your gay friends I said bye Wallace
again so is this the world they live in or is
it all like from Scott's head good question if 70
will ex boyfriends seven evil exes yes and I have
to find defeat defeat there's seven evil axes if
we're going to continue to date pretty much it's
a lot of baggage I invited Ramona over for dinner
tonight so you can't be here you have to break up
with knives but it's hard give me the bacon and go
do your dirt while I watch the Lucas Lee Marathon
who's Lucas Lee it's pretty good skater no
there he is ah I heard there was action in
it I didn't realize it was like a concrete
video game I didn't realize his style yeah
I wanna do that
I wanted to invite you over for dinner it's my
birthday dinner I think that's a really bad idea
God buddy break up with her are you even allowed
to date outside your race or whatever who care and
oh no oh no we should break up or whatever really
yeah stranger things it's not gonna work out
I wonder what this screenplay read like for
this how do you communicate all this they
probably were like listen we can't give you a
script we have to give you a storyboard so you
understand from here on out no girlfriends or
girlfriend talk at practice it's sudden death
now okay okay and Scott seems like a liability
that's right me that's for me hey you're here
yes like you said oh her hair's blue now
I changed my hair every week and a half
to get used to it okay bye see you guys
tomorrow you're just leaving oh boy dude
this guy is he's not committed uncommitted to
the band it's actually a really hard roll for
Michael Sarah because he's got to make this
[__] like a feeling yeah make it somewhat
yeah not so off-putting but she did it without
even making a big deal of it or anything she's
fickle impulsive spontaneous God what am I
gonna do oh what's wrong with this car so so
insecure are you a man the hell up you can get
the second half base tonight you think so if you
strike out in the next hour come find me at the
castle if I strike out okay win see you in 60.
it's actually a really good garlic
bread I could honestly eat it for
every meal and get fat no why would I get
fat bread makes you fat bread makes you fat
Maggie oh God I need a haircut don't I
what I got a bad haircut right before
oh my goodness now I can barely remember Scott
is acutely aware that his last salon haircut
took place exactly 431 days ago three
hours before his big breakup he's been
cutting his own hair ever since oh no that's
a PTSD it's a trigger wouldn't it what what
why are you wearing that hat I
thought we could go for a walk
I sort of feel like I'm on drugs when I'm with you
not that I do drugs unless you do drugs
in which case I do drugs all the time
you need some self-approval my friend did you
find the guy who's talking I think I'm about
to oh my goodness literally is traveling please
say that it cuts to Kieran and Chris making out
I was adopted babies
you dated a famous guy in ninth
grade we had drama hey this is
so bad he just followed me around you're
shocked I'm talking to you Scott Pilgrim
the only thing keeping me and her apart is the
two minutes it's gonna take to kick your ass
how's life is
ah hey hey
there's too many ask them how it
feels to always get his sloppy seconds
whoa Scott is doing pretty good right now
wow this is awesome how do they shoot that
whoa oh oh yes awesome cool they have these camera
work is insane there must be like some Cuts in
some of those zooms when they switch it now
between Michael Sarah and the stunt double Mr Lee
that is terrific
cool
the seven evil X's coming to kill you no let's go
but are you a pretty good skater
can you do a thingy on that rail
it's icy even killed me into doing a trick
like that yeah there are girls watching
that's there's a little little
glimmers of sound designer amazing
wow
sweet digs
wow that's totally bailed he just
dies yeah I think so hold on I'm
working for sevens you can't
say you didn't see this coming
axes uh
hey hey Scott Envy oh [__] been a while oh the
Captain Marvel how are you I'm not doing so good
right now oh she he's Desiring him now do you
have a girlfriend should I be jealous yes you
should I have this totally awesome girlfriend
who calls me all the time she's America she's
American I'm not telling you that Ramona I
gotta go to a nice chatting with you wait
like it's like a femme fatale presence
yeah oh hey knives you're outside
it's got here oh you know what
really yeah
foreign
look I've had it today can we not do this right
now okay little chicken next time I'll be
deadly serious next time what never mind
ah I love how colorful the characters
are yeah they're painted so distinctly
so what can I I got you how are you doing that
with your mouth never mind how I'm doing it
so I can just get my coffee over here whoa oh I
totally understand if you don't want to hang out
anymore I don't know I want to hang it's I don't
think anything can get in the way of how I [__]
perfectly compose your hair's getting shitty yeah
hahaha I'm jealous you're jealous I'm allowed you
left me for that cocky pretty boy we're playing
these Palace you should show totally come wow
Clash of demon header doing a secret show tomorrow
night and envy asked us to open for them no I hate
you whoa we're doing it we gotta get some Buzz
going we need ground swell we need stalkers
oh my God that's so sad
oh you did the fat ass white girl you know I think
you mentioned she was fat did you go ahead start
I mean I didn't even know there was good music
until like two months ago Ramona flower stole my
scar but I know how to get him back classical ride
shot what are these women so obsessed with Scott I
don't get it I don't get it maybe he has a Vibe
and you really just have to be there to feel it
oh I was gonna be here
oh hello hey who is that girl again Scott
dated her briefly briefly how old is she
this movie could have easily been overly
excessive but it manages to be very tangible yeah
yeah I know oh yeah oh it's one of her other exes
amazing Envy Adams would like you
all to come backstage all of us
it's cool how like even the actors were familiar
with are still playing in like something different
they're not just doing what they normally do
you know even Aubry Plaza it's been a while
I'm Envy I read your Vlog Scott and Ramona
soap average Ramona lived in New York played
the chaos theater for Gideon you know I'm
right I've kissed the lips that kiss you
oh what the hell just happened because she
kissed Gideon getting that girl's ex you
punch the highlights out of her hair oh no he
punched the highlights out of her hair foreign
you'll pay for your crimes against humanity oh no
I love this thing with the letterboxes show
we're going into a fight scene Todd's vegan
oh no it's like an anime character I partake
none of the meat by the breast milk or the ovum
of any creature with a face short answer being
vegan just makes you better than most people
I was only dating Lucas until the minute
Todd walked by we wreck stuff nobody cared
he punched a hole in the moon for me
wow a week and a half later he told me
his dad was sending him to vegan Academy so exists
basically you can't win this fight
so you're gonna have to give up on
this girl because Todd's gonna
kill you you used to be so nice
oh oh he's gonna use music to win
thank you
that's cool film jitters
whoa this guy is undefeatable whoa
that was awesome let's say we drink
to my memory fair trade blend with soy
milk can't drink soy I'll take one soy
thanks to him oh vegan's country you just
drank half and half baby speaking police
what the hell
he was worth three thousand Chris Evans was
only worth two thousand that's surprising
well he had super powers it makes you
feel any better you're the nicest guy
I've made wait is that good it's what I need
right now but not later Scott I don't have
all the answers okay I just like to try and
live in a moment if I can I just like to live
ex boyfriend's thing is messing with my head
exes why do you keep saying because it's not
just ex-boyfriends yeah man he really doesn't
know I was just a little bi-curious well honey
I'm a little five
what's on now
then Gideon best get his pretentious ass up here
cause I'm about to kick yours out
of the great white noise no way
oh wow that's so awesome
this is like brilliantly shot man seriously
it's so Whimsical but cool
damn that was like a really good kick whoa does
she have a Taekwondo background the precious
Scott must defeat me with his own fists I don't
think I can hit a girl you don't have a choice
hahaha
that's awesome
puppeteering fight
she could be coming from anywhere
just fall on her oh damn was the back
of her knees wait how does that work
what a hard way to go whoa Canada's just used
to murder is there anyone at this party that
you haven't slept with oh oh okay buddy did
you missed the part where I saved your ass
how could I I feel like we just watched our
sexy laundry in public Dirty Laundry you're
drunk had like wondering they both lack
patience and understanding I'm on Scott
cider about this though you know PS because
you're stupid sleep tally twins twins wow
the battle not only do I want to take part I
want to take them apart I'm getting tangles
awesome did you speak to Ramona then what
no she's totally here guy is she moving on
that can you hear that oh my God Jason Schwartzman
is he Gideon I don't know he has to be right
it's a band off this looks
like an actual music video
whoa Energy washing over the crowd
yes this is a Bohemian affinity
oh my goodness
what the hell whoa
now it's a monster fight
such vivid expression
excuse me whoa
I just can't see your show oh she's so sweet
poor nice I hate how mean he is there's okay
I hate it so much what did you want to tell me
that we have to break up I'm back let's get in
now I'm signing you right now for a three
album contract the people need to hear us
Scott well then you're gonna have to find some
there's a caution to be listen to me O'Neill
there you go obviously Scott's a valuable bass
player come on between you and I the whole
league of evil Lexus thing I was in a really dark
place when I put that together so forgiven he's
the originator of it he's gonna have to fight
Gideon knives is the only likable yeah person
in this world everyone else is so self-centered
self-serving I don't want any hard feelings so
I figured why not be the bigger man and just give
you a call is Ramona with you are you with me yeah
this pretentious party people you want
to fight me for her was that not clear
because I'm in love with her what's about
to happen Scott Aaron The Power of Love
if you speak then
awesome cool smart to use the flash
just so they could disintegrate
the heck it's the ultimate rock
and roll adolescent fantasy
I don't know his Love Sword uh oh
and I shall be forced to Grant you
a swift exit from the premises
in a fast entrance into hell
whoa I'm not talking to you I'm talking to her
you're kidding right no no she's she's not whoa
how do they shoot this
nobody stole anybody knives I dated
you and then I dated Ramona okay maybe
I forgot to tell knives right
away oh my God he's growing up
cheated on both of us he cheated on me with
knives no I cheated on knives with you right oh
cheat on these ladies all you like but you
can't cheat death oh wow truth is it was me
he was obsessed I was crazy about him he
ignored me I was more alone when we were
together than I ever was on my own just like with
him with knives so I had to leave so why go back
I can't help myself a random guy he just it's his
way of getting into my head it's that necklace no
I mean he literally has a way of getting into
my head oh yeah he is mind controlling so alone
bottle life
literally restarting the level oh my
goodness I love it you want to fight me
for her no I want to fight you for me Scott
earn the power of self-respect all right
how's it going back there you
didn't disintegrate into coins
no scum this badass hurt you know
we'll have my return no knives I
hurt you I cheated on both of
you and you're not a fat ass
really growing up
she's been afraid
I love the visuals of it but
why are we having this fight
well oh they have to fight
together to get rid of him
I love the way that blade
moves it's a residual wave
whoa he's gonna lose the level again he's ready
cool
nice whoa I don't know how they
did all of this is just crazy
it's great frenetic style man I'm what's happening
I'm blowing up right now you are blowing up
whoa so many points like how it's
on a pyramid like you literally
conquered the levels he leveled up can
you defeat yourself what [__] Scott
let's do it next week yeah yeah all right
be good yeah oh my God he learned to love
himself I said thank you though for being
the nicest guy I ever dated it's kind of sad
don't get her really she's been fighting for
her all along knives is the best character
I'm too cool for you anyway true mind if
I tag along oh maybe we could try again
how many women have you been with Scott
I don't know if I could deal with that
those are just the guys she dated
can you imagine how many well well
opening the door and closing new was the door
metaphor metaphor when you close one door opens
wow that was a fun film I was exhausting in
all the right ways it really was how do they
shoot that that was insane like I'm like the
uh the math that had to go into shooting this
is like in my brain can't handle it I'm like
how how like especially for the stunts you
know it's not like the over the head shots even
if sure it's a stunt man with a wig on whatever
but still the way the camera's moving and how
many like kicks and stuff that they do I'm like
there's no way that was in one shot all right no
idea yeah it's it blows my mind also I loved all
the characters I like that there was still two
women in or there was like three that are just
like deadpan like Aubry Plaza and Kim they're just
like yeah whatever you want to do which I loved A
lot of these like it was off the cuff people
very realistic and also very hilarious yeah
yeah I loved it wow that that is a brain frying
experience yeah it is a lot of stimuli coming at
you like the whole time I'm like is it just
is it 10 minutes too long in my own head
or is it just been a long day no I think I think
you are right about that like the fighting could
have been at the end I feel it cut down a little
bit when I got to the second fight with with Jason
Schwartzman I was like do we really need this
right now yeah this is cool and all but yeah
yeah couldn't we have caught to just him walking
out with like his his whatever his other person
I mean other than that uh yeah I know I mean it's
a yes you know it's been a long day for Tara but
still really entertaining like I was really tired
before uh when she showed up I was close my eyes
before she showed up and then yes we were like
woke me up it is a very it is a very dazzling
film yeah a very beautiful one to look at
and very unique on all fronts I love the
amalgamation of feeling like a comic book but
not just like a generic comic book at times it
feels like a manga to me and then it also has
of course the video game Vibes like they're
setting up all these references and it's got the
um I'll call it Bohemian affinity for all the kind
of music stimuli that you have throughout the
entire film as well yeah it's it's this is like
um I know this is this is before baby driver
yes that's the one this is before baby driver
but in some ways this feels more like Edgar
Wright incarnate you know what I mean like
it's an encapsulation of everything that the
guy loves uh in one Big Burrito you know yeah
and I I appreciated it a lot like I really
I really enjoyed it you know I the thing is
sometimes it was actually helpful that to be
here with you because this it happens with me
when I would get high and then I would watch
a movie like this yeah is why I couldn't watch
animated movies because I would get so caught up
in the visuals that I couldn't pay attention what
the actors were saying yeah and then sometimes
I would miss a line and you would you would just
repeat it and I'd be like totally because I'm
not even like on anything right now but even
now I have my misaligner too and then you were
repeatedly oh I didn't even catch it they said
that because so much is happening and being
thrown at you it's this is crazy cacophony of
stuff that's a cool little video game ending yeah
ending uh pixel three gig that's fun that's really
fun yeah I can't even think of all the cool lines
that I was saying earlier like what they said
because I can't remember but um but I loved uh I
I loved um uh all the acting all around like every
yeah every appearance because when they said seven
by the time we defeated Brandon Routh I was like
oh we still got a few more to go yeah just a
little every time I thought like is this gonna
go on too long right it kind of a little bit like
even with the twins and the dragon like it could
have been one time they've they they banned off
and then they get them but they had to go again
where it would yeah it felt a little prolonged um
so I do agree with that like imagine if there was
15 to 20 minutes cut off this movie you'd be like
this movie's perfect right because you would have
gotten to like the the heart of it of like him
earning self-respect loving himself and now
um I don't want to have first mistakes yeah yeah
and I guess just like still ending up with uh
good old flowers but getting the okay from knives
uh was it was sweet I feel like he didn't need it
I thought they were setting it up for him to end
up with knives until she was like your hair is
getting Shaggy and I was like that's what Captain
Marvel used to say and she was a botch I think I
thought they were setting him up to end up with
nobody I thought yeah I'd be on his own I think
I would have liked that more right um that
they were just like all right like see you
Scott and then she goes yeah see Scott and he's
just sort of there but he's like I'm all right
with that cut yeah because they're young adults
but they play it like they're teenagers in love
right and yeah I thought that when it came to um
Ramona it's still registered to me as infatuation
because he would still have had these like dreams
of fantasize about her but right I never really
felt like they never really got to know each other
right like I like their chemistry together and
I love I like them both a lot as individual
performers and this movie is more about like
mood Vibe style visuals uh flavor fun comedy
action like a lot of that is the personality
of the movie A lot of that is the K like this is
one of those things where I would say the style
is one of the characters of the film and yeah and
I really love the journey that that takes you on
um but yeah I think by when I'm just when I remove
that and I just look at the characters Alone
um yeah you're right yeah and I thought like a
part of this was the infatuation too but maybe
I just misread it I suppose I would I'm literally
why you're trying while you were talking trying to
think of a line that happened between him and
flowers that meant more or was more heartfelt
of like them learning about each other or their
right past lives I guess maybe they just chalked
it up to like well he's learning a lot about her
exes and how she operates but even then it was
still just x's and you gotta you gotta kill them
I mean yes he learned that one part when he goes
You Escape and I get it um and that's okay with me
that's just a thing that you've learned remember
you gave her that speech about being like I get
you now and these moves that you're making sure
but you don't necessarily have to do that with me
I think that was his intention I don't remember
the whole thing guys uh maybe that was the one
part that was the one little heart that they
added in where he finally understood why she makes
then disappears and stuff and she admits to him
why she does that but other than that we didn't
get much like of them discussing I guess what you
their lives or what they love or what they hate uh
we just it was sort of just like oh defeat these
exes now sure yeah I mean I like the I like the
Arc of How It's twofold of owning up to the fact
that he cheated not really any acknowledgment
about the whole you know statutory side of
dating right yeah and the rules are different
in Canada well he never slept with knives
true he only he only maybe he was he was they
didn't even kit or no they kissed once did they
I don't even think they kissed though no they
didn't it was the one the one time they kissed
she bombarded them at the concert jumped on
him kissed him and it was in front of flowers
and that was that would be considered their only
kiss but they never did anything other than that
yeah she's still seven hey man I get it I get
it I was just trying to make it less creepy by
being like well it's like Michael Sarah is a fine
actor and all but you know if you look like Ryan
Gosling yeah it's a conversation like oh I get
it yeah and he can get away with anything he's
Ryan Gosling yeah I mean but then you know he's
the guy Michael Sarah I'm like no it's a register
is a little creepy yeah yeah yeah before Charming
than I'll ever be but uh yeah I I liked uh I like
that I like the the inclusion the action because
they go right you know he's known for like the
horror that of course he's in action movies like
Hot Fuzz baby driver a very obvious one yeah um
uh the inclusion of like Kung Fu mixed with video
game type of fighting actually crazy really well
done with some great blend of like they would have
these one shots when he's fighting all the stunt
doubles where at times it's obviously Michael
Sarah but it'll be one shot and I'll notice
like with the way the camera moving it moves like
an anime which is a really unique style of like
the certain type of tracking and zooming going in
going out very smoothly and I was like are there
these hidden Cuts here we're flipping between
a stunt double and stuff and there's a lot of
times you could tell it was actually Michael Sarah
doing the choreography yeah I mean all that like
arm stuff it was very much him except obviously
when they would cut from up as well yeah those are
like that's a stunt double but still like I the
whole time I was just thinking wow how did they
do this how did they shoot this um who is your
favorite EX my favorite X in this no real life
you know yeah I would have just named something
some Miranda like I don't even know Spider-Man um
um in here okay favorite x man Chris Evans
is pretty funny and he I don't know he's he
he boarded well is that what you call it when
you're skateboarder you're like you're a great
boarder man when you said he boarded well I had
no idea what you were referred to yes I make up
words and stuff um I guess it would be I don't
know I mean they were all very entertaining but
I did like how like overly dramatic Chris
Evans was yeah he was the perfect like
80s 90s action star there's a lot of those like
80s Vibes too as well of of the kind of like music
video expression of the 80s I would say yeah that
would though with the way they would have a lot
of their dissolves and their transparency their
opaqueness I thought was really well done as well
throughout yeah yeah that's what I mean it's just
like a whole bunch of the Edgar I love uh I love
Chris Evans I thought Brandon Ralph was great
the vegan guy oh yeah yeah that's good I like
how it made fun of society a lot and it also was
and the other thing too is like there's so much
genre in here as well when you would cut between
the characters yeah the different X's there was
there was all these different genres that he was
hitting that like that like you made that comment
of a really strong character choices with each one
of them they all feel very different yeah they're
all distinct even even like Brie Larson as well
yeah uh feeling like that old Hollywood Starlet in
a way and uh the the music was also on like Edgar
Wright which was in the soundtracks very great too
um but the original scores as well very strong I
like that the music of just the bands the bands
were there yeah normally they were sometimes you
could really mess that up and it was really great
it was good I specifically like Brie Larson song
I think the most I was early jamming out I see
why she was the one who became famous Karen
Culkin was really fun too I love it so much
oh my goodness he's uh he just has a soft
spot in my heart he's such a good actor
um I feel like we've touched on all the
main stuff have we covered it have we
touched on it have we covered everything
my brain is like like uh we're both alone
very grateful there's very bright lights in this
room right now because they're keeping me awake
otherwise I feel like I'd be asleep on the ground
right it's been a long day uh well I think we
covered it we like the thing I mean Scott we we've
still felt like Scott was a little bit of a jerk
throughout it but so is everyone out everyone else
was mean to everyone like it was a lot of [__]
giving in this which I am great at so I understood
it it didn't bug me that much I didn't register in
my brain that like oh they're all jerks because
like I give [__] to my friends all the time
um but when once you said that and then how like
awkward it was the way he treated knives and you
felt so bad for her they did paint him in a light
where I was like oh come on man I thought at some
point he was just gonna be nice to her and be like
hey I'm sorry for like me being me I'm a douche I
whatever but that didn't happen he did do it with
Kim though true which was nice like he he had
moments where he redeemed himself at the end and
then you realize kind of that it was a self-love
self-respect thing that was ruining the the entire
time well yeah I mean that that was part of the
journey as yeah he was going like oh he people who
don't love themselves or respect themselves will
treat others like [__] or if you got their pain
and on others so yeah no there's like some nuanced
stuff here and it also knows when it's being
pretentious to the point where they'll acknowledge
it like oh I feel like I learned something here
you know and and I think that this there's a good
self-awareness about it to do it in a comical
way but also be just deep enough where it's not
overly in your face not not overt enough uh yeah
yeah the Blends were good Mary Elizabeth Winstead
saw her performance she's typical she's got that
that indie girl Vibe yeah that is like the kind
of person in an indie movie A zoidation now yeah
exactly yeah yeah those are the two characters I
often refer to when I sit with an agent I'm like
uh the roles that those ladies plays what I would
fit into these are the genres and the movies
that I want to be in they're great they're
great it was great I love that he loved it we
loved it all and we love you too so tell us if
you loved it in the comments yeah I think we close
it out do we go how do I with a patron shout out
all right so we are gonna do uh do it Andrew Hayes
oh Hayes Andrew hey hey might be a short stocky
white boy from Jersey but he's in love with
Tara oh my gosh and you know what he's gonna
have to do Sarah who Tara me Tara Erickson oh my
God Hayes Hayes likes he's gonna happen you're
gonna have to to fight all my ex fight all of
the X's there's 75. my God the number here how
do you not have that Jesus that's a large number
oh I'm like a squat you know sometimes we'd hold
hands for like six months and you know how they
get upset when I'm like I think we should stop
holding hands doesn't matter Andrews is gonna
have to beat all them up you're gonna have to
be I'm talking Bronco remember Bronco Bronco was
your first true love tell them about Bronco that
you have to beat up oh Bronco uh Bronco uh yeah
I mean I liked him he got me like a Winnie the
Pooh uh stuffed animal in like seventh grade
sweet guy and he took me like in the go-karts
once and I like that yeah so when I think back on
it no one else has done that for me so I get real
sad that's why he's the worst one Broncos sounds
like you should get back if you see this video
I miss you hey Bronco She Loves You Bronco yeah
she loves you and not as much as Andrew does and
apparently Andrew loves me a lot more why are you
trying to get in the way Andrew when it's clearly
a hot doesn't belong to you come on well I mean
he could come in here too I could I could just
see if it works with me with
Andrew oh yeah maybe you can
have both go you could do both you know why not
those dating apps that goes on the west coast no
problemo oh my God just fly back and forth foreign
foreign